Five four, three, two, one. Boom.
It's over. Boys here. We did.
Here's cheers. Cheers. Cheers.
Cheers his now. No, remember
November. Here we go.
I remember November. I
like that. First of all,
who's fucking stupid idea was to do this.
God Damn Fitness Challenge Tommy Buns
last year we did a nice calm 15 hot yogas.
Yeah,
it was so awful. Not even close.
Not even close to this. No.
This was so much more difficult
and I didn't expect this,
but I like it. I liked,
I think it's fun to be
competitive with your friends.
It's a fun thing to not fuck around, but
like, like isolating something like this.
Oh, it's a year. You get to see different
sides of people you didn't know existed.
Oh yeah. Jesus Christ. You
worked out too. You have no idea.
I don't think anyone,
anyone gets the real perspective
when Joe is focused on something.
I've never seen anything
like that in my fucking life.
Well I know the funniest because like
everybody's competitive and this brings it
out. But like the funny thing was like
Bert being like, whatever Joe does,
I'll do double. Definitely.
He was like, fuck that
and that and the other
thing I didn't expect ever.
I thought Ari would just be like,
whatever,
I'm just going to walk in the East
village. I was worried about him the most.
I didn't think you were going to do shit
about him the most from the beginning
as I know are his brain. Yeah, I'd
be like, Nah, I'm out. Fuck this.
That's what you were saying that though
three days in and you were texting like
this is dumb. No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no. He says
that this is what he's saying.
He's saying that and he means it
while he says it, but he's also,
I'm going to fucking kill these guys and
then he gets really serious and I got
serious but I was looking for loopholes
in order to trick you guys did not work
out.
So I thought if I get like a bunch of
points like all to join in like seven or
eight days in and then you can be done.
No, that I'd be like, I'd be like,
what the fuck? Like, yeah,
I've been secretly working out,
but now I'm too far away so don't try
to catch up. Oh, right, right, right.
Like some psychological
snickery he was doing,
he was saying he should just do your
regular workout and see what your scores
like a than to control.
That was a big fan of that one to your
regular fucking weight cause you were
entertaining that for a second. You're
like this in the beginning I was like,
this is so stupid. This is junk. But then
I was like, I can't lose. And then uh,
then I thought about it and the other
thing I was thinking was this is what I
was,
this is what my plan was.
My plan was to keep up with you guys for
two weeks and then after two weeks to
set aside a lot of time and
about and then lap us. Yeah.
Well now just go psycho. I was
like, I'm just going to go psycho.
I'm going to put up pace that I don't
think anybody else can keep up with for
like the last two weeks,
the last two weeks I just said I'm
going to put in some 600.5 days.
I put in 1000 point day.
That's that's, that's when I,
that's when I stopped looking at you
for context. I was looking at the,
when we started this month
and I put in my 700 point day,
everyone was a little bit
like, wow, Bert. I, by the way,
I ran almost a marathon that day.
Have no fucking clue.
I was just looking at my goddamn phone
the whole time. Just checking the points.
Always cheap so people don't know
what the points are. It looks plain.
If you get 70% of your max heart rate,
that's three points a minute.
If you get 80% of your max heart rate
or above, that's four points in minutes.
So we all tried to stay in the 80 range
because that's where you get your money,
right? That's where the work out for
an hour in that range. But you know,
a hundred a heavy workout.
It gives you 240 points maxed out.
We're maxed out. Yeah. That's just gives
you context of what a 600 which was not,
I did a 930 feet and it worked out.
It was over after that topic.
I was in New York. He'd
call him. He's like, dude,
he's just fucking going dragging elk
around. He has it all the whole time.
He's dragging us around. That wasn't even
that one. That was, that was the elk.
The hog hunting day was
mostly hiking mountains day.
That was like a 600 point
day. Oh No. That's when, when,
when you were there and you were actually
working out in the mountains as well.
Yeah. We thought it was like, I was
like, what the fuck? You're like,
if I would've been like, guys,
I'm Mel cutting. This is,
I made the mistake of jokingly
saying, oh, I got him.
Joe's on an elk hunting vacation,
and the hunters were like, dude,
it's not a fucking vacation. It's
work. And I was like, easy guys. Well,
you've got a backpack on and you could
walk as money as the most I've ever
walked. It's 12 miles in a day and
you walking up and down in elevation,
you're going up and down.
Like I,
I saved it one day because it was so
ridiculous because I had gone up and down.
I forget it like 130 flights of stairs,
some something fucking crazy.
But you ended up getting your,
what'd you shoot on this hunt?
A thousand pound elk. That was big elk
like relatively quickly, right? Yeah,
the first day. Thank
God. So then I came back,
I came back,
but the 935 point day,
that was my big deal was a thousand points
because I did 935 in the day and then
I did a podcast and then I did a hundred
later on in the day just to stably see
you guys anymore. Yeah, that's what
I was wondering. Like there was like,
I didn't have, I, there was a, it was a
part of, it was time management. I was,
I suffered socially.
The huge part was like who had the
most time to spend in the gym? Yeah,
I was here two Mondays ago,
last Monday and it was,
it was popping out at the comedy store
is going to hang out with everybody,
you know. And then it was like, Nah,
it's 10 o'clock I gotta get a couple
of hours in and then all your walls,
your workouts were so late so fuck you.
I got say that.
Fuck you with you post in your goddamn
workouts in the middle of the night.
It was so deflating.
Go to bed.
I've got a 200 point lead
and the wake up and go,
how am I 600 points by
I tried to break spirit.
It was fun cause that's the other thing
already went through when he got this
tracker and he found out
all the work work arounds.
So he would build up work points in his
tracker and then he Bluetooth it in the
middle of the fucking night.
Oh I also do the workout.
The workout is doing workouts.
I come home from the seller,
1:30 AM and then I'd be like lemme change.
And go out there two in the morning.
Oh, you're going active? Yeah.
I thought you were uploading in
the middle of the night. No. Oh,
you can see the time. The time that
he was actually doing it. Yeah,
it's the freaks we're out.
It was a sweet,
calm and I thought that because
already was so out of shape.
His heart rate was just skyrocketing.
Like Ralphie walking upstairs and then
Ori and I went on a walk on a hike and I
was in the yellow the whole time and Ari
was barely in green and I was like, oh,
he's in you.
He's in really good shape.
And then you did that day with generally
bought that theory really hard.
That hit that hit that
it was just that made,
it was out of shape and
he was saying in a lot,
I was like barely walking,
but because he was selling it
so hard and I called him, I go,
how to go on the hike. He's definitely a
better shape to them immediately. Well,
it's a psychological thing.
You don't want to think that a guy who
hasn't been working out at all is in good
shape, but I think you pushed yourself
through the first week or two.
Then you got in good shape and then
I kept going. Okay. First of all,
I had fought by plants. Okay.
What was the plan? Okay,
Michelle Wolf offered to give.
Let me just have her wear the thing.
Wow.
From day one.
That was definitely the fallback that
was going to happen regardless. Oh yeah.
She ran 10 miles a day every day and
when I asked her, I was like, hey,
would you wear this thing for
me if I needed to do? She goes,
I know what you're talking about.
Absolutely. I'll wear it for you.
I will stay in the right zone.
I'll tell no one.
She feels left out because
she thinks she would laugh.
She's what's east probably
none of this is what we do.
Like two long cardio sessions.
I did five and a half hours on an
elliptical after running for an hour.
What it, hey, get one of
those crazy days, 935 points.
I ran for an hour and then I stayed in
the elliptical for five and a half hours.
See it go and you check it, but
fucking broken. Got 300 points.
I need to talk and he checked back in.
30 minutes later you're like, oh no.
It's still going. It's still
going. Yeah. I just fuck, well,
I wanted to see how far I could go. The
thought was like, when you're tired,
how tired are you? Can you take
another step? Okay. Can you take two?
Okay. Can you take three? Can you just
keep going? I bet you can keep going.
Let's see how long I can keep going.
And then you get to this point where
you just just think about breathing.
Just think about greed.
That's why I was thinking about,
I was just thinking about in and out,
so just trying to stay almost
like a meditative state.
Trying to stay in the zone and I was
pouring sweat. I set off the fire alarm.
That's what it was. So much
steam. It's set off the fire.
That was like four hours in.
I feel like that's a story most people
don't get to tell about themselves.
You know, and it was madness.
This is not how I work out.
I work out for like maybe an hour at most.
I hit the bag,
we'll do some rounds,
I lift a little weights.
I'm not trying to kill
myself like this was,
this was very interesting cause I didn't,
I didn't know what,
how my body would respond to like
a month of psychotic exercise.
Did you do the thing you got to
do the things where you would,
you'd be like the voice would
say you've got to quit, quit,
take a walk for a little bit,
then go back and do it.
And then if you just go like,
oh I'm at 4.8 miles,
let me just go until five oh yeah.
Or like,
or like I'm almost that
halfway through this hour.
So let me just get to 30
minutes and it'll be downhill.
I can stop there if fucked with my
obsessive compulsiveness really bad. Yeah.
Cause I get to the place where I go, all
right, I just want to get to 200 points.
And then I'd be like, Oh shit,
I'm only at 950 calories.
I want to get to a thousand
it's like, Oh, I'm right,
I'm right by two 20 I want to get to do
20 and then it gets to a point where you
get, I believe it's like it's,
you get in the zone when you go,
I'm just going to keep going.
I'm going to, everyone's asleep,
I'm going to keep walking.
And Dude,
it got back with me to the point where I,
I mean we'll talk,
we should talk about physical
breakdowns and a little bit,
cause I know all of us dealt with
some sort of physical breakdown,
but I was having nightmares that
you guys had fucked with my tracker.
I'm putting it in that I was younger
and lighter so I wasn't earning the,
I'm not even joking.
Oh No.
The night in a panic and
checked my fucking stats.
Somebody got into your Shit and hacked
it and I was like, these migraines goes,
no,
I wouldn't put it past them that yeah,
you get that parent or it can I
tell you my other cheat? Uh, okay.
I figured out pretty quickly that the
way they do your Max heart rate is um,
your age minus a certain number of
minus your age and then you get it from
there. Then when you actually run
it, it'll move up or down from there.
But right away I was like, oh, okay.
So I entered my age and before I started
I wrote to the Maya Zone people and
said, my idiot wife wrote my
age and wrong. I'm actually 74,
uh, morning 44, not 7,444 the other
way. And they're like, all right,
we'll change it for you sir. So you put
together at seven year old man profile.
Yeah. Hold on, hold on, hold on. Hold on.
The whole month you are working on is
that a four year old man had done that?
The problem is,
I had already said it as the other thing,
and so it'll say you have to,
then you have to have a brand new thing.
It didn't work. Oh, so you stuck in
the front yard. It wouldn't be great.
It would have been great to be able just
to walk around casually earning yellow
the whole time, which I could have
gotten. That would have been insane.
That was definitely a good cheat in my
mind that that went wrong. I was like,
fuck. I feel like that one would have
disqualified you. Oh, for sure. I can
still do that. I'm still on the fence
with these fucking five hour hikes.
He was taking.